the penny farthing was the first machine
to be called a bicycle
they're old they're funny and for some
still a big deal uh sometimes i go into
a local bike shop just for a bit of a
joke and ask me if i've got a tire to
fit my bike and then bring them outside
have a look at it
people find the funny farthing almost
hypnotic i don't know why i can't
explain it but people just love seeing
it and it's just a real pleasure to
share it with people richard being an
already avid bike racer discovered penny
farthing racing on an internet forum one
night
so i entered immediately very excited
and then realized that a i don't have a
penny farthing and b i don't know how to
ride a penny farthing but he overcame
those hurdles
i'm the current uk champion so i've got
title defend
but penny farthing racing isn't as easy
as it looks and it sure doesn't look
easy it's a very dangerous machine to
ride you're sat up on top on the point
of balance virtually so if anything goes
wrong you tend to be going headfirst
over the front of the bike the bikes can
be up to five feet tall and that height
has its benefits racing one of these
bikes uh pretty high up you get a
fantastic view of the crowd it's the
best way to see the event here i always
tell people height is not the only
benefit the penny farthing has big
difference between riding a funny
farthing and a normal bike
is you can't slow down very quickly
you've got to watch the road ahead but i
find the biggest difference is the
smiles on people's faces when you ride
one of these things people just love to
see it they smile they wave they pull up
take photographs
i've so many conversations with people i
would never ever meet without this bike
and that's the joy that people just love
seeing and talking about it
you